he's on the album yes yeah I wrote him
an email I professed my undying love for
him in this email and I said I love you
I've always loved you I've loved you
since I got your autograph in 2001 at
the MTV Video Music Awards I love that
you always work with the same people for
instance Rihanna and she's hotter than
me but I'm funnier help me get my rap
Grammy and who just wrote back okay you
you you kind of corrected some of his
less politically well he was a cue to
being homophobic you know by so many
people because of his lyrics but I
thought was nonsense yeah and I came out
and supported the faculty isn't that I
appeared on the Grammys with him doing
Stan instead of Dido I did the Dido part
- I was the one that took the El out of
Dido
in France we've been amazing friends
ever since he's he's an amazing guy I
spoke to him last week I interviewed him
last week for magazine and I just adore
him yeah I do too
he's quite a poet isn't it Oh am I
allowed to say what's in your house oh
yes for my marriage
well I David and I did our civil
partnership I got this package from
Eminem and shows you how homophobic he
isn't
we had to diamond encrusted [ __ ] rings
they have remained unused